okay so this is the first half of season
four of Steven universe we finally had a
little bit of free time and we just
Marathon through them um and uh that was
a bit of a grind yeah quick note on this
was kind of dull until we got like the
second alas when we saw and like yeah
just like whoa it happens yeah
everything else I felt like we kind of
saw you know like not not too much
variety I I'm not gonna lie it's the
first time in a while where I'm like I'm
kind of fighting to stay awake through
some of these episodes yeah like there's
definitely been episode so it's like
okay that's kind of a filler that's kind
of filler but then they get to something
even though fillers were kind of
interesting and different this just
can't seem like well yeah we saw a
variation we practice eat onions friends
I hate onion and everything associated
with oh you know and it's like it's I
feel like he's a terrible characterizing
but just something about him I don't you
know what why um he insists upon himself
remember everything is um so wonderfully
pretentious I don't I'm not a fan yeah
is what it is because it's not like oh
he's so annoying or he's so terrible or
he's a just something about him really
I think his friends just he seems kind
of creepy and now that we've seen his
friends I'm like they're kind of
psychotic I just but I guess the idea
apparently the moral of that I guess
we're getting ahead of ourselves or the
moral of edges seem to be well it's okay
if you're weird yeah but I'm like they
were kind of crazy like maybe unhinged
weird I'm not sure it's good to be like
hey that's cool you want to kill living
things like this let me grab this a bug
we've all kill bugs and stuff is still
Oh good-sized bug a beetle minding its
own business in a forest I'm like geez
I'm not that bored yeah after you Ray
said okay we're going to have her so
okay let's start with the first one
which actually I really like this one
kindergarten kid this was the yeah I
wonder why you like it yeah I love
anything roadrunner coyote
it's funny because right about the point
it was like one minute in that we're
just like man this just kind of reminds
me like Roadrunner coyote cartoon
they're like a scene or two it was like
oh actually it is an exact one a
straight-up omage it's peridot and
Steven trying to get one of the wherever
that was a kid kind of stones that were
or the gems that were growing there in
the kindergarten and it's just I not
only is it a good old Bosch but it's
good slapstick yeah I feel like these
were kind of like yet still bold a song
and stuff but you would still like the
time out of them was so fast in my two
favorite forms of comedy are the ones
that always get shit on and that's puns
and laughs there yeah and honestly
they're both the highest forms of comedy
and fuck the rest feel like I did like
all comedy by Alfred Hitchcock up on oh
I like all copy fun I do like I like
those two the but to me the funny thing
yes the funny thing about either is to
execute them properly like everything or
just a room for become derivative yeah
you know what but to execute it properly
you really really need to know what
you're doing like I've seen doing the
MCS we've seen so much shitty slapstick
yeah but would you get like perf and the
moment we watched it bad yeah yeah you
get like a good Tom and Jerry episode
good Roadrunner kinda really walk up a
great wait an elastic was okay that I
did it like Edwards the great ring yes
the fans of the early Sam Raimi film
yeah and the glass is nice and good and
there's a solid amazing about it and and
this even I think the middle parts of
rat race of beginning ending that movie
sorry but the middle parts of that are
amazing um the miss nale there like
there was one moment in particular where
pair that falls and then gets up and
just says I is black and obviously yeah
perfectly cut is um how much pain can
you get out of this with you know
combined with good timing it just make
is perfectly it's the you're gonna say
something you know while you're already
dying ah and then something hits you and
just makes me even worse it's like the
finishing touch and I thought that was
great I thought that was very funny
apart from that it just was like I like
I like the example just like well put
yourself into shoes like how does it
feel to be pelted with these
marshmallows I'd say delicious but you
know it's like oh it's annoying it's
like yeah well that's what it's like for
this thing like endless suffering I'm
like that's a pretty good example of
that was an insane amount of
marshmallows yeah and that bad yeah seem
to be in the running bag um but yeah
yeah I guess that's it like yeah there
wasn't much you know yeah like character
or moral or anything but it's like I
didn't need it I'm fine with the plastic
in the coyote Alijah they even got the
background to look kind of like it but
still in their style so I like that um
no you're fusion this is where there's
an interview with smoky quartz from the
garnet and pearl fusion this one just
bored me I just didn't care I mean I
guess I'm okay I mean I know it's like
oh the physical strength and everything
like that here's okay you know great
dancer brings more wrong I got it but it
was like took way too long to get to the
point which is they were turning it into
about themselves and really it should
have been about them and then in the end
Stevens the Diwani er that I I still
would rather call the milky quartz thank
you no no no no that was a mess amethyst
is the smoky quartz sorry I was
confusing later when we saw what happens
with watch 1200 some smoky quartz saves
the day and then they get to explain
their powers at the end I'm sorry but I
got that best one it just it took just
like that a lot
it just it took forever to get there
yeah it was a weird setup yeah usually
down for weird set us but that just
wasn't grabbing me and then the weird
games like they had to do I I really
missed the Yeller from the prices or
anyone like you man yo man
like if they had more like death stars
coming out or maybe there's like a band
instructor and there's hints of who's
out there and who the audience is stuff
like I would like to have actually seen
them or something but yeah I don't know
it's almost more like a David Lynch
dream that's why yesterday yeah that's a
good way yeah so I mean I don't it
didn't grab me I can't think of a great
great moral it just that was one where
I'm just like I like the idea it just it
needed to be like five minutes not 15 or
what yeah alright next one's buddies
book this is where they find a book by
William Dewey's first mate buddy and
this is a guy went over and sort of
discovered all these various and funny
is the pirate log from The Secret of
Monkey Island but still pretty system
pretty amusing for the best jokes in
computer game ever um but it's a bit
official cute this was the copy nothing
episodes are bad by the way I did life
besides I can't think of a bad episode I
don't like the onion one um I did like
there's something adorable Lakhani I
gotta start studying up for the seventh
grade even though it's summer I'm just
good lord I think that's kind of thing
like I just I was sitting next and I
just shut it nerd um it but I do like
that when they discover that book she's
just like back home work like that
tossed the books aside um yes but it was
a pretty good one I yeah I got it is
cute and I won't do this I really like
tomorrow on that because there's a lot
of people that want to do blank first
yeah discover versus I like the idea
know it's all discover but you can show
it in a new way that it's like it's
discovering it in a way that no one's
ever seen I feel I guess what a lot art
does and even criticism and stuff like
that so I like that idea I thought that
most stories haven't already so it's
about execution yeah exactly
that's kind of what that was about and
plus it's a pop point that came in later
yeah so like it comes back
hey we got a mindful education this was
a this is the one where Connie kick some
ass and if you
really bad about it and it's really the
way to come to grips with their pain
when they fuse as Steven uh Stefan II
this was already gonna make your joke
what name did you prefer coven coming
over Stefani I'm just like its Connie
and Steven it should be coven clearly it
just rolls better it sounds better yes
um I haven't covens are bad at such a
group of witches those fucking hex your
shit uh this is fine it's good honestly
out of all the early episodes I like the
first one but honestly this is the first
one or my ID is pretty good like it I
liked this one because I felt like we
were learning about their characters and
what was driving them nuts and you know
except for you you're just like really
that was it what if she said okay no it
was like as I was saying like you know
he says I beat up a kid and I'm thinking
like like be table like you know
something like that because I didn't
went to town because I didn't know and
then when they show a Goodfellas how the
back is begun to be monitored you're
done but but pretty much what was is
that he just sort of like disturbed or
accidentally and she flips him over and
ago but you're just like faceted and I'm
just like have you ever been flipped no
that's not it no I was saying what's on
a matte one and that's Phil I was like
no no I was laying that know what I want
a hard don't move floor no that's fine
you're back no because I was saying that
you know she should have said I flipped
a kid but then that sounds like I
flipped a kid and that doesn't sound
right either so yeah maybe that's
casually yeah that's because you're like
yeah you want to say I Swift the kids
just like they would read that we're
designing dialogue kill any what's wrong
I know why is your beat up I mean it
hurt again I would that flip though I
just was good crack and they're just
bored like organs arm but but yes I
serve like the meditation as they
- I feel like kids they have like a lot
of life you know whatever built-up anger
or stress and I don't know what to do
like that's a good episode for that one
else spirit of the way at the end yeah
with them falling and it has to be a
spirit in a way we were just humming the
spirited away music go away down I knew
you were good
[Laughter]
yes III like that one that one like um
future boy Voltron oh god what I was
speaking of Miyazaki I loved no waiting
in action
what a waste of a great Oh or reference
yeah I think the others I'm gonna Cabana
Kiki want Kiki's yeah delivery sir I
think it was more tone opening that I'm
just saying I didn't even like I guess
this episodes alright um but no you know
what no I don't like this kind of boring
I'll say this I look but it's a future
boy like future boy Conan is an old old
old old school like pre Ghibli show that
Miyazaki was involved in and you should
look it up exactly really awesome if you
can find a copy anywhere um but it
doesn't end the Kiki I feel like yeah I
feel like Voltron is like referencing
big wasn't that Zoltar or something I
thought was Voltron well I figured it
was Voltron but there was also Zoltar
and big and that's what the hell so
anyway so so uh Steven takes over this
futuretelling machine give good advice
to a lot of these people fine I was
waiting for the advice though to get way
more like insane just like you know time
to pull the plug on that machine that's
keeping your grandma alive and fly like
I your shit is oh oh the birth control
didn't work congratulations question
mark I like just that's a question
really for your doctor yeah that's the
closest we got that made me laugh are
you
but then this dude comes and it's just
super super duper as it turns out he
used to be part of a comedy routine with
Savannah forget his real name you don't
anything else Miley that's right because
it's Miley and frowny says that now I'll
remember him
um all right upside-down which is
already a little funny that like I'm
just immediately thinking like there
they have to be referencing Sinbad
because I had a passing comedy yeah oh
why don't you copy anymore I wasn't any
good I was just like huh I don't ever
stand on being that bad I saw like move
it I won't be it's probably Dade if I
know it doesn't hold up I smell like oh
that's awful it is
he was so deadly that Shazam like I love
him in that movie I never made that
confusion by the way I don't know where
that cerro by oh you know that movie
everyone thought existed but then I'm
like no cuz it didn't exactly want to
know here's the funny thing about it I
did because somebody else was trying to
tell me about the movie and I'm just
like hi yeah no I guess I I guess this
like yeah I guess now that you're
mentioning it I remember it but I like I
never would have come up with it on my
own but somebody was talking about it as
if it were a real movie I'm like yeah
come back yeah she go bad but like yeah
and I was like but yeah I don't know um
but my buddy goes they meet up a there's
no matter what there's going to be
sadness like in your future pretty much
what I kind of like but he goes and they
still meet up even though they know
they're going to be sad and they somehow
end up making each other feel better
which is like wait a minute that's still
it then they're not totally sad
I see an empty bottle of scotch and a
lot of missing the painkillers Xterra I
thought that ending was a little bit of
a cheat but yeah I guess you could argue
enough that you know maybe it's not you
know because they still did to have
Sanders in there just this was last one
out of Beach City this is where pearl
wants to show she's a badass and go to
like a concert and stuff like I did it
is this one's a lark but I did enjoy it
um yeah it's those promise of lesbian
action midnight I love all sing come on
in the last episode we got a fair amount
of gay I mean granted they never kissed
or anything but they were acting like an
old couple pretty much like a couple
were of each other's arts I don't think
I'm dealing with it that's just humming
and
her oh girl honey someday you're gonna
find it um yeah I didn't really go
anywhere too much yes I love pearl Love
Finds you huh justifies a woman looks
like road follows her and tries to break
a few rules and stuff like that and I I
am i I love this episode of also
questioning like I don't know in case
you have those moments where I'm like I
guess I'm an adult cuz and I have to
think about this like sorry how are you
to show like the responsible role model
like basically running away from the
police
yeah cuz I'm like well I guess she's a
crystal gem but I'm just like oh my god
I just turned old
notes because I was also thinking like
you know pearls gonna like know
everything mamie I mean there may be
question think of the like oh I don't
have a license oh I can't explain about
from other planets stuff it's like but
but there's a ton of other times where
you have to tell people you're from
another planet like yo Stevens friends
are really Maris and I'm just shot for
his math question so I know that would
did right have a good one
how's it been amazing like pearl just
whips out a piece officers like sure
just guns it I thought you have is like
she was going to still like whatever go
pay a fine and turn herself in or
something I I thought it was going to be
Thelma Louise I I thought and that was a
serious Analia that was a high okay what
there's so many unanswered questions and
I I think we just broke the ending the
Steven universe somebody call Rebecca
sugar yeah yeah can we rest calmness and
have an end right there that would be
mending sensor Sopranos
I would have sat there with my John
McGraw and just gone I respect that shit
it's assisted me no offense but I
respect that you had the balls to do it
just just leave a may not I liked it I
will pearls like my favorite character
so I I just like you're trying to be
badass and like drinking the order the
the apple juice oh yeah I just there's a
lot of things ya know about going and
drinking today yeah I don't know I
didn't go well at all I said all these
things and then she just gave me some
sort of code and I was like uh yeah Wow
next was our favorite episode onion game
this bucket next onion find some friends
in the woods as like oh well they're
only summer friends so Stephen hangs out
with them they're still a little
psychotic they pretend to die and like
you know come back which is like okay
playing but then they're like let's race
the bunch right now let's kill them and
no not even let's kill them let's have
Stephen kill one so they're kind of okay
and I think this is my onion fucking in
a few episodes earlier has a crowbar and
a mask and it's like no I can't get
behind this unpleasing nectar no and
this is my problem is I think they're
trying to go for the morals it's like no
embrace the weird
everybody's different diversity
something something the 23rd century man
alone all night Larrabee you know you're
that watch yeah yeah that doesn't work
when you're reaching serial killer
levels like I don't sit there and like
it's like we should embrace the weird
it's like my friend likes to abuse cat
we should just embrace the weird like
here is it no no I can deal like there's
some point where it's just like you've
crossed from oh you're just quirky and
weird and we shouldn't bully people too
you may actually be a murderer and I'm
not going to bully you I'm just gonna
keep my distance yeah keep my baby push
you a little towards the therapist you
know
yeah or be like you should get some help
but yeah there's I don't know there's
something about onion and his friends
that rubs me well because I usually love
this type of character someone like from
it's always sunny in philadelphia when i
had just these awful people but they're
they're kind of put in the place where
those who are struggling with their
small child
yeah no no no either god i love it
because i think alike adams family and
stuff like that's our bob's burgers like
Louisa's yeah like a
or Archer those are all terrible
characters and stuff they'll tell you
what the world and if you haven't yet
there's a yes an environment and whereas
like a character like Louisa Bob's
Burgers is one of my favorite characters
ever you put that same type of character
just beyond bizarre and weird and like a
you maybe psycho way in this it doesn't
work like the universe they inhabit it
just doesn't work in this universe like
weird weird works you know what's a
weird kind of mean-spirited I know
there's a pyramid and the character
might be is not very well - fine no it's
never look at me and then kind of know
that it's doing this terrible stuff and
if I can't get a grasp on what this
character is about and maybe that's what
people find interesting about em oh hush
up your phone um but maybe that's what
can people find interesting about this I
mean I don't find it boring they don't
show the right stuff to make it in
Toronto see I'm not gonna lie I feel
like this is we want to talk about
Achilles heels in the show like your
your little kryptonite chinks in the
armor or whatever I think this is one of
them because when I think about all the
human characters that are kind of jerks
none of them I enjoy watching like you
can make jerks in a show in like
interesting to watch I can't think of a
single one yeah Renaldo's annoying
doesn't know it Mars to be doing onions
but their closest would be the mayor
played by Joe Hudson like that that
would be even better
yeah not the Penguins that gem villains
are amazing - yeah any of the human
other when we get a good relay yeah I
guess you're right but it's a problem
it's a legit problem with the show I
think like for some reason the ball is
always dropped with that type of
character a neutral kind of care I feel
like those characters have gotten
funnier over the years like the Nelson
months and so on so far like they've
made funny bullies and I can hear some
people gay fix it but you get to person
like them oh my god no but feel like you
give you like them have to be enjoy it
in them you can join not liking them
videos yah - well just call it Frollo I
hate that kid oh he's so terrible but I
love - hey look it yeah all of us in
Joffrey on Game of Thrones yeah you know
I mean no
yeah I don't think I ever hated a
character more than John but it was a
blessing to why I got it I'm like almost
a pointer it's like I need to look away
but can yeah I know I mean that's like I
enjoy watching how awfully amount of I
might get it I follow an eye on em so
and three characters have that quality
they are literally they're like what you
call nuisance enemies in games like you
know the Medusa heads in cans yeah yeah
I guess this is just a nuisance it's
just a nuisance through them like
joining a canyon yeah they don't have
anything it's just a nuisance
Sully agree like we have gem harvest
this is two episodes put back-to-back
that really could have been one I don't
know why they leave it to the first half
is about a pumpkin dog and then they
abandon that I already not like to call
it a pumpkin I'm shocked they didn't
make that job and then you get the rumor
I said puns of the highest form of
comedy that wasn't one and then the
landlord from Aqua Teen Hunger Force car
that was the best thing about this
episode of her like oh my god Carl is in
this turns out is Greg's cousin and owns
that barn and has I guess I could just
say it elements of like cliched Trump
supporter touring all over on you know
kind of thing and it is good lighter to
do like doing like with a cups of them
in the plane and a later episode I just
want real except when we finally get
that wall built along the Mexican border
we'll keep all the Mexicans up and then
finally America will be waiting I raced
but I didn't call it like it is so it's
like on the one hand I love that he's
the voice actor for that because
anything that guy says is kinda like
John Benjamin just he says they just
want to guess one of those two just
shows up at the bar and that I just
wanted be like man I let the milkshake
in the meatball and the fries but this I
would get away from this crease by it's
great but it's the typical even a maybe
you take whatever turns or whenever have
it's this guy that comes in doesn't like
these new people that are here in their
culture and their ways and stuff and
there's a culture clash and he tries but
doesn't actually hire them magically it
all works out and somehow doesn't turn
into a normal family thing
giving where you just all shout things
at each other and then somebody got a
racist diatribe and that's what kind of
bother me about this episode
you know realistic is fun I don't want
well first of all assume it's all right
to make a statement but it's just such
an easy wrap-up I'm like no and I don't
know and no universe do I see this is
the thing - even is something that is
relevant as soon as the episode starts
you're immediately like okay there's one
of two directions they can go they're
either going to make up at the end or
he's not going to compromise and maybe
in the future they will or maybe they'll
find a little silver lining or something
and I just be like okay that's going to
be the ending why am i way through two
episodes to get to this um even if it is
like I said it kind of relevant
especially today I'm the America's very
very divided but it's one of those
things where I just feel like you know
okay it's going to be one of two things
it just felt false I'm sorry like when
you try to take something that complex
and wrap it up like that quickly it's
like so yeah I maybe I just I just
didn't buy it for a second I'm like no
like all of a sudden it's just like and
then I turn fox news off saw Jesus and
had an epiphany and now I love
everything and every like yeah it is
where what like if I get suddenly in to
kill a mockingbird they decide not to
press charges you know this was so good
I'm not gonna press charges where like
to like either side is a different
fringes like anybody has a Thanksgiving
where that magically worked out and it
turns out that you just made peace at
the end and you all decided that it was
about love and understanding or did like
half of you just get completely
shit-faced drunk and all you remember
was a shouting match by the other effort
to bet it's more like liebelei
yeah right the very best it's like a
slight compromise yeah the compromise
being we're just going to stare at each
other in stone-cold silence and talk
about nothing in particular because by
god if somebody mentions hey guess what
I saw on Fox News or MSNBC shit's gonna
hit the fan yet exactly yeah like it
just I don't know the soccer baby even
taking politics
out of it I mean which I got I feel like
it's impossible because it's very ave
yeah but I mean but even if you were
right down boys look I don't like change
like no yes I mean it's like just more
white value doesn't like change you've
um yeah I mean this is that you baby if
you worry you're just to say okay these
two a very differences these are two
very different cultures they've been
living two very different ways a guy
that's been away for years and years
suddenly coming back and yet we've been
you know i J this is an occupation and
I'm not saying that they should have
done this necessarily because we're
already got enough filler already in
this season but you would have needed
five episodes of him coming back and
slowly you would have needed to peridot
this shit to get to the point where I'd
be able to believe that but one magical
one magical night what is because we
pray go talk about this one up but I did
the one last thing I'll say about it is
that it in the show Roseanne which I
think handles stuff like this very well
actually awesome yeah no but but one of
the things that doesn't even really
connect those just a family difference
one of the daughters goes off get
married without telling them or anything
is pretty much moving out and really
drives a huge you know just split
between her and the father another
daughter off to college came back it was
a completely different person yeah what
is this a daughter don't know is that
that yeah we love but but like you know
so she's gonna leave and she's gonna go
live with her husband and the father
you know John Gilman I mean just doesn't
talk to her does the silent tree man
when she's leaving
he doesn't say goodbye and she's gone
for a long time and it's like holy shit
this is an you know four episodes in
episodes he's just not even talking to
her acknowledging she exists and this is
why you're likeable main characters
doing this and it's one of the things
for any like things it's the time I
guess we try and do it as real as
possible this were a different show
where they had a history of just it's
just sitcom II oh it solved easily but
this show has managed to kind of try to
take complicated issues and stretch them
out and take their time with you're
really kind of did that too and I felt
like no no no I'm going like that's what
the that's my problem with like if
Steven universe like was one where
it's like oh okay there's a history of
just not really giving a fuck enough but
there is it it's actually set the bar
yeah honey high for itself so I just I
don't know I bet it if a look at cheap
shot
and I'm not just saying it sound like a
cheap shot on everybody yeah no you know
it was whatever that is you had yeah I
don't know whatever differences you have
I mean whatever it's gonna take time and
I do feel like yeah isn't watching that
feeling ok well that this can be wrapped
up in a day I'm you know you know what
it is good my noted it's before House
Mafia it's like and then Michele says
something funny and then they whip out
the sad guitar music and then Danny sums
everything up in some sort of moral and
the end like hit that boy did you take
away perfect into the next one with
three gems and a baby oh I just don't
like baby stories I'm sorry I like this
is fine but it's like any time I see
there's a baby in an episode or a movie
or anything I'm just like shit
I said literally that's probably what
we're going because it's a baby yeah and
this isn't even done that bad but again
it's star trailing that territory of
okay the gems getting used to Stephen
being Rose who is now a baby now a child
now boy weeks and a lot of yeah like oh
that's that it's a god-awful episode but
it's just like what was new that was
added here that I already nothing really
good video just them coming to grips
with that it's Stephen and not Rose but
it's like a good we can count
could we put that together do my no sir
yeah connect the dots that this happened
between everything else there is there
is no man is longer this goes on I'm
like losing a little bit of patience
with some of the fillory ones yeah um I
I feel bad but yeah it is one of those
because they're not bad they're not
really that badly done but it's one of
those things where it's just kind of
like or you know even the messages
aren't that bad but it's like yeah I
just sort of feel like this show me so
good and so talented that when we do
kind of get these fillers that are not
are not that great it's kind of like and
man couldn't we get to you know like
like the next episodes even just great
segues um this is where we finally kind
of get back into the big plot and and
you know it's funny else just realize
because sometimes we say it ever get
tired of the big plots let's do one or
two light episode then we're going times
the light episodes let's go back to when
they usually have the pretty good rent a
pretty good time in a while where I'm is
like a little bit way too many fillory
yeah this one like literally near the
end I just turned to you and I was like
oh my god shit - yeah liar again I I
give a crap like I just really am as fun
as the the wily coyote episode was like
I give a crap because it was just like a
chasing there were there weren't any big
stakes like you could still do a
slapstick episode they have stakes
involved there were no stakes really so
but this is the first time like whoa
like I am completely invested again wish
this had happened earlier but you know
and I'll take it now and for what we see
because we only saw one other episode
after this like apparently like the next
five or six after the ones we saw is
this continue I'm sorry my bear was
garnet just Steven I can't tell you why
you can't go there well why not
because if I do tell you you only want
to go there more and I'm gonna like then
why would you say and she would really
fitted with I shouldn't have said that
now you just want to go even more really
like why would you say that I love then
uh ya know that this was pretty cool and
weird this episode was awesome my god
yeah best best so far out of the unit
we've seen even better the next one we
were introduced a blue diamond already
but this time he gets his hair I love
the way this character is designed
because whether or not she has hidden
the outline of her in the cloak is
already so strange
it's creepy Oh odd and I don't know but
then when she turns and talked and you
see her eyes throwing do yours when
conveys Karen there yeah
yeah with the nylon your designer man
all right so she looks great even
without the cloak and then the fact that
her voice doesn't shit she says
terrifying character but she just was
supposed to whisper monotone and then
her sighs like I didn't really like it
was seeing her next to the the pink
diamonds tomb or whatever like the size
of her was legitimately creepy kneeling
there and when she comes up to Gregg and
she's just so huge I'm like yeah there's
something even for a cartoon like this
things kind of terrifying like it said
yeah big looming shadow and the way that
the whole scene was so creepy with no we
should talk to him
this was no planet resident I'm like it
just had this creepy funeral like
atmosphere so wonderful what like in a
good way it's a wonderful mix of
contradictions that were not used to
it's a giant woman that at first has a
shape you can make out then we see it
it's sort of like this very stretched
out long the very sad face but still
says very menacing things but also
misses somebody very closer she's crying
- there's a lot of shit going on yeah
you know what used to be a pretty big
guy
and now you know convinced in her hand
and all that kind of all these
contradictions that Jerez so don't match
in just the right way there is multiple
and if there was a creepy like element
to with the way that her sadness and
depression was so profound it would make
Steven cry Steven was seeing through her
eyes
there was some kind of horror movie
about there like go generally if it
won't be it was it was a really good
episode everything about it I'm just
like yeah this is just a nerve you got
the good build-up to it as well as I'm
not wanting to say what it is uh it
comes back again to what the Rose do you
know whether you feel like you feel like
it's a tomb like it's a grave and just
everything about this episode
feels like a ghost like if you don't
that can kill usually outside of
breaking the fourth wall in the middle
with the South Korean animators like
that now that was great but like that
was the one moment of brief there was no
levity in this yeah like none that was
like there one moment is hahaha funny
because we're about really ready to get
shit real yeah I was joking the light
before I realized that they had done
that that that was going to be the big
secret just like no Steven you can't go
there you can see what's there when he
goes there he sees all the Korean
animators doing Steven universe and
realizes he's a fictional character but
I thought that was a great in joke yeah
I you know even the animator I mean I
don't think it wasn't it to be her by Yo
easier from the bank looks a little bit
like Rebecca sugar a little bit uh what
do you look like uh oh you know what may
be nice a shorter hair I'm fast like I
took that animator book Korean like that
was Jonah you don't three is the the
front of her um but but yeah from the
backs of the longer black Karen that's
like yeah could do could be that I
forgot she has Rebecca sure is right
here but yeah and even that probably
wouldn't make sense I mean it's like
yeah I do love like there's something
it's so endearing and also completely
fucking horrifying the way she's just
like your plan it's going to be
completely destroyed by this massive
super weapon but you I like you I'll
keep you as a last part of the legacy
like I'm like on that's engineering but
also genocide Allah ya know it's all
these great opposite extreme even Hitler
love this dog
ya know it's just and it's so creepy and
unnerving and I just it's you know that
got me excited again to see more episode
it's like these are terrible we were
never anybody it's just just Kevin I
mean I know that coming yeah yeah I know
it's a little different when we have to
watch these all in a row like
particularly when you get up to twelve
we used to do them five at a time but
yeah I was just hitting like a breaking
point I'm like seriously will something
fucking happen yeah I feel like I'm
wondering if I would like these episodes
more if there were a few more of like
the serious ones dropped in there I
still think I would have tiny issues I
did with them but you know I be a little
kinder to them possibly
which brings us to the last one
adventures in like distortion this has
one of the best returning jokes ever
where they're going through space and
they're buying this oh wait all I'm
going to say is shit with loss let's
just shy
lost my like I have never laughed so
loud that when that happened like I just
that just amazing like brilliant call
back to an earlier June but you don't
not even a joke it was such a serious
episode I mean I gotta - yeah I'm like
really brilliant fo not only and I just
have that be a dumbbell joke okay I
still feel so bad when I came in with
just wandering aimlessly in space well
then the others are there to like surely
by yeah it's just God but ya know that
was brilliant
um I see it's just about getting ya a
day at work it was just it was a kind of
giant ludicrous speed joke yeah just a
build-up tada
I am wondering though when you do I did
I did like like it gave you an insight
into what's driving Steven at the moment
which is father so he's like having I'm
looking - yeah Carla is just so
determined you know it's like you know
what kind of go we're going to get a
fabrica I mean she is my dream super
Aloha epic moment sometimes it just
destroyed by the simple things like
we're going to space we're going to get
Tom - Tom Greg
well that was like he's like you know
I'm sorry I didn't listen I'm sorry I
went to Korea and it's about a 20 yeah I
shouldn't have been listed in the
military yeah um the things I saw it was
like mash man I am wondering though if
you're the have like the old-school 3d
glasses like the red and blue 3d glasses
would that work when he's traveling at
them because they lie below an eye and
look like you but I don't know it was a
very the episode because I don't have
Kurt you know I don't think I think they
would just do that just for cable and
they would do that kind of just for fun
like hey if you do have a TM one like
somewhere you know locked away or so but
I have no idea it could be just it looks
like that Oh but yeah I'll count with
you it's just a getting there episode
but it's not done fine I know that
there's purpose yeah it like I'm willing
to put up with a little of and I'm like
okay well at least we're going somewhere
yeah I can only just think I feel like
just filler episodes are better
interspersed and I just feel your baby
is this closer from the start
yeah there are two
at the most three at a teller so how
many do you watch 12 yeah we are like 10
episodes with a lot of filler and I'm
like that is too much yeah I'm I gonna
pay with some filler episodes because
I've enjoyed some of the ones in the
past yeah a lot of they're done well
yeah yeah but this this round I'm just
like yeah I feel like cause like I just
I didn't read the plot or anything about
it's just sort of seeing I'm like okay
well are more like this in the future I
just saw diamond blue diamond pink
diamond yellow diamond and like in the
next five or six episodes I'm like okay
obviously this is going to be the big
shit guru diamond pink diamond purple
horseshoes green clovers and they're in
blue this is probably be like just what
they call the steep Stephen bombs where
they jump like oh and don't forget
rainbows it shows fucking full rainbow
so um yes sort of first half of the
season got oh I mean it's not awful just
a slow drive start but it looks like
it's getting really good again um and
yeah I'm Kyle with you just like I think
I can take the filler episodes more if
they're just dispersed in smaller chunks
but just having yeah ten in a row is
really tough um so yeah I don't be you
know it is we're doing this so after the
fact and then these kind of like it's so
funny because occasion I will just get
like these messages or me which is like
oh my god maybe David univision yeah
everything changes everything and I have
no idea if if I've encountered that
episode or now like there's so many
times where I've gotten like messages
like then we could have like I don't
know but but that's the thing I get on
those I got really - and I'm thinking
like we could've have a cry don't know
I'm hoping that because I feel like I
wanted to be more sure but I feel every
time I get this oh my god
image and I'm just like I don't I'm like
which episode was it like I don't know
now I'm assuming I don't I don't really
know I don't know because I don't want
spoilers and shit I would get messages
like that and I'm just like I don't even
finish them because I'm like because I
swear to god you fucking spoilers for me
a hand maybe in the next chunk oh he's
in there somebody anthesis yeah I guess
what this is weird because it's like so
late though I'm like did
did we see it wasn't when his dad was
abducted was it like was it
pearl hitting on the like concert chick
was it uh like ya know you know it is
funny like how yeah like I watch an
episode like physic I just I don't give
a shit like about because it like I just
look it I was like oh it's like somebody
like flirting and like I just white like
I don't get what the fuck is the big
deal like was that a lot of a deal isn't
I know I don't know I'm just saying like
I feel like well there was all this talk
earlier on uh you know because it has
that kind of quality too but I just look
at them like okay she's openly flirting
got her number and I'm one completely
okay man just like who gives a shit well
I didn't know if it was being talked
about her I am I have no idea but I know
the garnet fusion was a big deal because
I thought the legitimately good twist
because yeah like oh this actually
wasn't fusing the whole time they're
both really tiny so Chi equals out a
slightly taller human being and I'm
generally like I guess I don't know
maybe it's just me because I try not to
involve myself in the the internet
culture wars cuz it's just it's work and
what's not fun
um but I don't know I just I watch what
I like and I see a scene like that I'm
like well that's cool like she's looking
to put herself out there again and she
may have met somebody and I'm like it
doesn't even occur to me like there was
like oh my god catch them first out cuz
like that
technically lesbianism is like well
technically my favorite is to Bieber
like well technically she's a gem so
therefore to the Emma cool yeah why are
you calling her I'm like yeah like I'm
like okay yeah sure like that if you've
been dealt with that if you get repeat
no no honey you're like who's she saving
again it's like a big deal or I think
somebody mentioned it now it's just more
because of the controversy with some of
the air of your stuff in the previous
seasons and I'm just like and here this
scene comes them it's like great cool
like him and it I guess maybe to with
the whole korrasami thing like and what
a big deal that was for either side of
the fence
my god yeah I are the aromas as grand as
time is yeah and it was neither of those
things yeah can you believe it I'm like
I know I really can I sort of thought
they would end on a note that connected
more to the story and series I'm just
like that's cool like it started to fade
in like just as I was watching it slowly
then I'm like yeah have you told me I
would be seeing this kind of thing like
20 years ago on like Cartoon Network or
on something meant for kids I would look
I think bag of the days is like Don't
Ask Don't Tell like and here it is and
I'm sure there's some sad poor bastards
out there good that's my backup stuff
now but you know fuck it I don't care
yeah I I don't know I just think it's
it's kind of cool like and it's that I I
like tell stories because like the re
talked about the haunting and the remake
where it's all just about like a lesbian
lesbian dimension that was being can I
ever tend to be more I'm was it and it
was like here like these are just two
people like trying to go out or like ask
each other out and I'm like it's so
simple like people overflow probably I
mean with it any of this stuff I mean
the thing that I always think is like
you know just the options and the
opportunities and what I like about this
show is that there's so many different
setups for you know different fusions
different creatures different you know
relationships you know there's so many
different relationship I mean yet a
woman that transforms into a little boy
you know so it's sort of all these
variations and to me that's the cool
stuff not ooh this was done that's great
that was done but what did you do with
it it's you know it or what interesting
way into all internet like so much of it
is organically part of the plot it yeah
exactly
are is characters it doesn't feel I
don't care if you were sworn in what did
you do it well and Germany yeah they had
to go we do it in a way where even this
is done a million times after is it
still interesting how many times I see
things and they just feel just
shoehorned in like it's like we need
you okay character and it's just like
does this story need a gay character I
mean it could go one way or the other
it's like okay so what is the character
minute lives Dreams motivation like
husband uh but um gay character yeah I
like it
yeah I hate that like that tokens and
there's nothing talking about her it's
like she's an interesting character yeah
they're all pretty interesting how we
teach at the jerky characters like
please say yeah the only card in earth
or the hobby can't get it what on your
jerks more well yeah maybe she's just so
nice that it's not in her regret being a
gadget to just watch the British
comedies they made some wonderful
journey won't be me I just want to play
multi-hour is red or black books just
watch all these great Black Card black I
feel for a character yeah so um yeah
that's about it
next time we go through a large chunk
you'll be the second half of the season
and we'll probably wait for 12 episodes
of the season after that couldn't seem
to be way because will Wi-Fi these are
good but man 12 9 8 brain yeah so of
cuckoo oh we shall see you guys later
namaste
you